This world has more secrets.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
They released a new Godzilla X Kong trailer video.
The director Adam Wingard, explained more details
about the new titans in the movie
Kong's Infinity Gauntlet
that he's running around in during the trailers.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
in Big Reminder as the trailers say
they've actually moved the release date of the movie up
two weeks sooner to April, which means
we all get to see it sooner, which is always good news.
there's a bunch of brand new footage
with Godzilla who seems like he's
inside the Roman Coliseum for some reason.
I don't know if he's in the middle of a fight here.
Not really sure what's going on outside the coliseum.
You can see his tail
curling outside around the base, too.
I've actually been there.
I don't know if the scale quite works out here.
like he might be standing behind the Colosseum
because the Monsterverse version of Godzilla is huge
compared to the Toho version during Godzilla minus one,
which is also a fantastic movie.
If you haven't seen it.
Like I didn't do a big video on Godzilla minus one,
but it is awesome.
So if you haven't seen it, definitely check it out.
But it is a completely different vibe.
Godzilla and Kong is more of like a giant action movie.
Godzilla minus one is more of like
a traditional kind of Godzilla movie.
there are bunch more scenes inside the Hollow Earth,
the central area inside
Skar King's Lair,
where he's ruling over Kong's captive race.
There are few more scenes of that new Shimo Titan,
I believe this scene here
where you see the Titan breaking through
the ground is meant to be Shimo
And since the last trailer came out, we've actually
learned that Schimmel is being controlled by Skar King.
He's supposed to be the only titan who can control him.
in Shiloh
is meant to be the most powerful titan on the planet.
When the movie picks up, making Skar King
technically the most powerful titan on the planet
because he's controlling the most powerful titan
In Together, Shimo and Skar
King are meant to be like evil
versions of Kong and Godzilla.
So you kind of see where they're headed in this movie,
like a two on two tag team match during the film.
Not quite full Royal Rumble, but we're almost there.
That would be like Godzilla.
Final wars inside the Monsterverse
like the Monsterverse version of Avengers Endgame.
Godzilla Endgame.
They have to leave some place for these movies to go.
way they have to be able to escalate the movies
as we go along,
And apparently Shimo was the Titan
that was supposed to be in the last movie.
Godzilla versus Kong is one of the main antagonist,
but I think they decided
not to use them, probably because they felt like
Mechagodzilla, Godzilla and Kong.
The three of them together were all the main character
titans that the movie could handle narratively
in like I said, they wanted to be able
to escalate things in the next movie.
So it made more sense to have four main character
titans in this new movie.
you could think of that as like Titan creep,
like power escalation in anime.
there's always a problem like that.
Like there
always has to be another, more powerful threat.
But if you get too powerful,
then it just becomes ridiculous.
Speaking of getting more powerful,
we see Godzilla go full pink in all the trailers.
They haven't said exactly how this Godzilla form
is meant to be more powerful than his other forms,
like classic atomic breath
or as temporary thermonuclear pulses.
But I think the peak energy is just meant to be
another evolution of the character.
something meant to put him on par with Simmons
powers and abilities,
who's supposed to be more powerful than him
when the movie picks up.
So naturally Godzilla needs
some sort of power upgrade during the film,
the director, Adam Wingard, also explain
what's going on with Kong's infinity gantlet.
Like perfectly balanced is all things should be
you have to offer to tag team.
One of them is getting a big power up
Godzilla in his pink form.
Kong has to get his power up too.
That's where his infinity gantlet comes in
they said that is actually meant to be apex tech
that monarch took after
the events of Godzilla versus Kong.
Like Apex is a company collapsed
after the events of that movie
Monarch absorbed most of their resources in technology.
So the arm brace is meant to be based on tech
they created for Mechagodzilla.
So you can think of it as Kong
getting a Godzilla style upgrade.
but even though he was Mechagodzilla,
he was actually based on King Ghidorah.
So it was sort of like a fusion of Godzilla
ideas in King Ghidorah.
they've alluded to this whole phenomenon in the other
Monsterverse movies, even on the Monarch Series, too,
like the trickle down
effect of all this research into Titan
biology in all the technology they created based on it.
The device seem like it is more of an arm brace
that he gets later in the movie
because most of the trailer,
he doesn't have it on his arm.
My early theory right now without more footage is
he just gets into an early fight
with Skar King, who beats him
and wounds his arm, creating the need for the brace.
but it does look like they're breaking ground
all across the earth, coming out of the hollow Earth,
like you see Kong coming out here near the pyramids.
you also see Godzilla over in Rome near the Coliseum.
the battles take place all across the earth.
But because you're coming from the whole earth,
it's much easier for them to get around quickly.
they've also revealed more details about Son of Kong
to the mini Kong, as they call them in the trailer.
He's technically not Kong son,
not biologically related to Kong.
I'm just calling him that for the video.
but in the context of the movie he's called Zuko
which is translates to child in the reddish brown
hair makes him seem like he came from a pair of apes
that were being held captive by Skar King.
And at some point,
his parents were killed orbiting him.
And I think the trainers are implying
that Kong is going to adopt him
the way he kind of adopted Gia
when she was orphaned on Skull Island.
end, by the end of the movie,
Zuko will just continue living with Kong.
And it's not really clear, though,
where the next movie is headed after this one.
If Kong and Godzilla stay in the Hollow Earth
like they team up to kill Skar King and Shimo
and free Kong's race, does that mean that Kong then
is going to become the new ruler of the Hollow Earth?
Like he literally sat on the throne in the last movie?
if that's true, I think Godzilla would probably
just continue to reign supreme above.
Like he wouldn't stay on a throne
literally next to Kong with even though they're bro
their pride is going to rule over
their different domains, one above
and one below
until it's time for another Avengers level.
Titan team up.
use that to remember that monarch
now has a station inside the Hollow Earth.
So it sounds like they're going to be
staying down there longer term to one of the other
biggest things in the trailer,
though, is what looks like Gere's race
of Titan worshipers
like she wears a special gown, approaches the pyramid,
which seems similar to the structure
Godzilla was living in during King of the Monsters.
that place that had all the manmade depictions
of their history worshiping the Titans.
Part of the idea was, I think as she descends
from that race in a portion of them just sort of living
above ground on Skull Island with Kong and his parents
before they were killed by skull crawlers.
Jia then gets orphaned and adopted by Kong.
So Kong finding his race in the hollow earth
sounds like it's meant to mirror Jia's story.
Finding her race in the Hollow Earth
to like most of her
people stay down there and just continue to worship
Titans.
Dan Stevens is one of the brave
new characters named Trapper, and he just meant to be
a tracker who helps Eileen Andrews and Bernie Hayes,
who are both back from the last movie
You remember the Bernie Hayes,
even though he's mostly used for comedy,
is actually meant to be pretty intelligent,
Like he used to work at Apex.
they seem like they help uncover
what's really going on with Skar King Shimo,
maybe find some of their weaknesses
and use some of Monarch and Apex
leftover technology to help Godzilla and Kong
kill them.
There are a couple other new secondary human characters
in the movie too.
They haven't revealed too much about them
or about the rest of their storyline.
I'm expecting another larger trailer
around the Super Bowl sometime that will reveal more
of the actual story in the movie,
like how things actually progress,
But it seems pretty clear from the early trailers,
even though it's kind of cryptic, like Kong learns
about the rest of his race, they're being held
captive there, then tries to free them unsuccessfully.
then Godzilla helps him.
But they also run into Shimo in.
At some point, Skar King threatens to take over
the surface role to using Shimo and the other titans.
but because the movie's coming out in April.
We should get a bunch more footage pretty soon.
Post all your theories about the new Titans
in the comments, though.
Let me know where you want them to take the next movie.
Like, remember, they had to escalate things
in each new movie on the other side of things, too.
They're still finishing up the Monarch
Godzilla TV series.
There are few episodes left as a me posting this video,
they just revealed
a couple of new details about the Hollow Earth,
some new Titan lore.
I don't know that it's like this
all over the Hollow Earth, but at least in the part
where they visit the TV series,
something happens here to basically
slow the flow of time or change the flow of time.
basically explain that Kurt Russell's
military character who got stuck down there
in the Hollow Earth for a little while,
stopped aging essentially for about 30 years.
So when he came back, everybody
else was 30 years older, but he looked the exact same.
And he's meant to be about 100 years old
in present day, even though biologically
his body is only about 70 years old.
they also just brought back another character
from the past who got stuck down there for even longer,
who also did not age.
She still looks like she's in her thirties,
even though she's meant to be the same age as Kurt
Russell's character,
who's supposed to almost be 100 years old.
even though Godzilla is a big part
of that show, metaphorically and literally,
they've introduced a bunch of new titans during that.
But because they typically save the really big stuff
for the finale, we'll see what else they wind up
revealing.
Generally, I'm just expecting some huge reveal
about the Hollow Earth and Titan Lord,
just in general Generally, the feeling, though,
is that the writing for those human characters
on the TV show is actually better
than the writing for the human characters in the movies
that they've had so far.
So when a lot of people are like, Why don't they just
put the TV show Humans inside the movies?
Now that might be their plan long term, but we'll see.
I think they plan on doing multiple seasons
of the Monarch TV shows.
I'm assuming then they'll stay on the TV show for now.
but if you spotted any other Easter eggs or references
in the new trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video, just write it
below in the comments and I'll do another trailer video
as soon as they release one.
Ryan Reynolds also just dropped a brand new Deadpool
three teaser trailer.
You can click here for my video
on that and click here for that new Daredevil
Born Again Teaser in the Echo Post-Credits scene.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!